the code playground you will find course  collections on genomics transcriptomics  metagenomics and data center in each  course you will load transform and  visualize data in r or python from  single bar plots to complex  multi-dimensionality reduction  techniques like principal component  analysis or clustering for data mining  including classification and regression  that will allow you to group data  objects by feature similarity and train  machine learning models for predictive  analysis not only will you learn about  the methods you will also understand  them by applying the analysis to your  own data sets and modifying settings to  see how each line of code contains  important instructions to transform a  complex data set into a fascinating  discovery from the very basics to the  cutting edge loading transformation  visualization as well as discovery of  patterns in real data sets used by  researchers to study and understand  biological phenomena at the molecular  level